ja gut dann du jetzt noch hier habe ich
über 500 bist du blöd verhilft sich doch
wenn ich sage ich meinte fünf erhöht was
wieder fest willkommen zu einem neuen
video ich habe heute mein bruder wieder
hier noch mal so wir machen das heute so
wir machen einmal hier dieses video für
mein channel und ich hatte ja schon mal
oder wir haben hier schon mal ein video
dazu gemacht dass wir auch einen neuen
channel zusammen haben und da kommt halt
noch ein zweites video genau jetzt auch
online deswegen das ist in der video
bestellen klickt er drauf nach diesem
video und text auf jeden fall ab weil
sie den trainer nicht abonniert haben
macht es einfach mehr geil und ja wir
spielen heute wer bin ich
dabei geht es um also wir schreiben um
einen zettel einnahmen von einem
youtuber muss nicht berühmt aber müssen
wir erkennen und müssen inhalt ging er
erkennt dass auch alle müssen noch an
wir dürfen nur mit ja und nein also nur
ja und nein frage stellen und auch nur
mit ja oder nein beantworten
und das müssen wir jetzt erstmal die
zettel vorbereitet du kannst es sei aber
durchaus nicht erlebt hier keine bilder
sehen könnt erst mal ganz simpel bin ich
bin ich männlich youtube in deutschland
ja habe ich über 200.000 beenden
hier habe ich über 400.000 ja mach ich
les cayes ja du bist bin ich wenn ich
mache ich youtube singe ich noch nicht
mal kennt man kann ja nie wissen mache
ich sowieso kommen
okay du bist bin ich zwei wenn ich zwei
also auf diese person noch blockt diese
direkt über das zu zweit machen
islamischen mache ich so phlox und ich
mag keine let's play also ja nein
ich mache kein let's play und in köln
wohl nicht in köln
nein ich wohne aber in deutschland habe
ich über 500.000 abonnenten aber unter
einer million abonnenten
du weißt nicht wo du musst in exter nach
ob er überhaupt 400.000 hat ja okay du
bist habe ich über 200.000 arbeiten denn
ich mache ich meinen channel allein du
ist bloggen die 2 keine ahnung haben
hunderttausende leben aber die kennt
zugestimmt ich habe über eine million
abonnenten und ich bin zurzeit das
schränkt das schon mal ziemlich eine
macht musik ich glaube ich weiß ich
schon aber ich frag jetzt noch weiter
weiter aus wenn ich noch vergleichsweise
junge familie loches bewusst nicht viele
abonnenten ja was geht war falls ihr das
video seht ja gut dann du jetzt noch
hier habe ich über 500.000 bist du
blöder ergibt sich doch wenn ich sage
ich meinte 50 eigentlich 10.000 5000
6000 ja das ist ja ich gedacht also da
kommt er nicht
außerdem wachsen weil das video kommt ja
noch sein unrecht servers ja ich war ein
bisschen tipp geben ja das war jetzt mal
hier sein kleines video also das video
haben welt gemacht um auf jeden fall
noch mal hier auf das andere video was
was richtig ist also das ist fakten wie
bei uns
also so über uns als brüder checkt das
auf jeden fall hat wie gesagt eher links
in der video bestattung ansonsten will
ich sagen falls auch dieses video fall
dass auf jeden fall noch da und hier in
der endart kommt noch mal hier auf der
linken seite zu meinem video von
vorgestern das war was jungs ein mädchen
toll finden in anführungsstrichen und
auf der anderen seite mit dem letzten
von uns beiden fragte aber abonniere ich
vergessen
haut rein